For centuries hypnotism has been explored
as a therapeutic or entertaining tool, but
it has a reputation of being fake and shrouded
in mysticism. So what does science say? Is
hypnosis a real thing?
Take a second to close your eyes and imagine
a lemon. Imagine the smells of that lemon,
it’s colour, it’s shape. Picture the texture
and feel the lemon on your skin. Now take
a knife and slowly cut into it, releasing
the juices. Take the slice you just cut and
squeeze the lemon into your mouth. Now open
your eyes.
Is your mouth watering at all? You see, despite
being presented in the media as a form of
mind control, scientific researchers describe
hypnotism differently. Hypnotism is a state
of consciousness involving highly focused
attention minimizing competing thoughts and
allowing an enhanced ability to respond to
suggestions. Hypnosis, from a scientific perspective
then, is similar to the kind of focus your
brain feels when reading a book or watching
a television show, where the rest of the world
seems to “slip away”.
And research has shown that it’s actually
capable of shutting down our automatic responses.
Like reading words right in front of us. In
this test, try and say the name of the colour,
not what’s written on screen (TEST). So
in this case you’d say “Blue” as fast
as possible. Try it on your own. Kinda tricky,
right? This is known as the Stroop effect.
It’s difficult because our automatic process
of wanting to read the words trips us up in
our ability to name the colour quickly. However,
if the words were in another language like
dutch, then you would have no problem naming
the colours as the word doesn’t have meaning
to you...unless you speak dutch.
In one study hypnotized participants were
given the stroop test after being told that
would see the words as gibberish and meaningless.
As a result the stroop effect was temporarily
eliminated, and participants could name the
colour without error or delay. When this test
was run in an fMRI, participants showed lower
activation in the anterior cingulate cortex
- an area in the brain involved in resolving
conflict and competing demands; as well as
a reduction in the visual cortex, which is
crucial for recognizing words.
The Harvard Group Scale of Hypnotic Susceptibility
shows that hypnotizability follows a normal
bell curve distribution. Very few people experience
no sensation during hypnotism, many people
will respond to ideomotor-ideosensory direct
suggestions, such as lifting your arm involuntarily,
and a small group of people will respond to
cognitive suggestions which impact memory
and perception and can create hallucinations
and selective amnesia.
It’s can even be used to modulate pain.
In one study, while hypnotized, participants
were given a painful heat stimulus on their
right hand and rated their pain. They were
then told they would be given the same heat
stimulus, when it was actually a non painful
temperature, and they rated their level of
pain the same. In fact, their brain showed
the same level of activation in the anterior
cingulate cortex.
Scientists have also scanned the brains of
people faking leg paralysis as if hypnotized,
and then again later when they were actually
hypnotized, and saw increased brain activation
in the right orbitofrontal cortex, right cerebellum,
left thalamus, and putamen. Meanwhile, when
faking it, they showed no such changes - which
suggests hypnosis has a different neural basis
than those imitating it.
So while many hypnotists or subjects could
seemingly fake hypnosis, under a brain scan
it becomes clear who is lying and who is actually
hypnotized.
If you want to see US get hypnotized by a
professional for the first time, check out
our video on AsapTHOUGHT where we do exactly
that! It was a...interesting experience! Click
on the screen or use the link in the description.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!